seuls les arlésiens savent qu'au milieu
de cette plage vite une femme de 105 ans
aujourd'hui les visiteurs de léonis sont
très spéciaux ils viennent de belgique
et d'estonie remplir une mission qui
leur tient à coeur
répertorier les centenaires du monde
donc si votre belle et votre mère
n'était pas marié notre centenaire est
d'une grande lucidité complètement
alerte
elle est en bonne santé elle a pourtant
travaillé dans la canne de 12 ans à 60
ans évidemment nous l'interrogeons sur
le secret de sa jeunesse
d'habitude comme à 20 h est passé à côté
mais la crise a fait qu'ils les uns des
aliments et bêtes ont fait sauter
maintenant des vapeurs les deux
chercheurs à la chasse aux centenaires
sont épaulés par cette femme dynamique
membres d'une toute jeune association de
guides touristiques
elle compte parmi ses missions le
classement des centenaires en martinique
c'est une bonne chose si sa venue sur
croyez moi j'avais zéro son argent mais
ils sont venus ils ont payé leurs
billets sans cesse qu'il y avait la
mairie les a accueillis une certaine
façon et nous là maintenant on a
quelqu'un qui puisse faire vraiment
donné la véracité de notre territoire et
vous devez savoir qu'ici on ne peut pas
voir nos cadres identité si on n'a pas
le d'état civil si c'est pas écrit et
croyez moi les registres très bien tonné
les deux chercheurs ne s'arrête pas
qu'aux visites
il passe aussi du temps en mairie pour
compléter les informations trouvées sur
internet les registres de l'état civil
sont épluchés ils remontent jusqu'en
les anses d'arlet compte moins de 4000
habitants
les recherches sont donc un peu plus
rapide pour le moment au niveau
11 darley on en est à 13 mais on doit
que regarder les gens qu faire de
vérification trait sur 1000 donc ça fait
1,3 pour cent de gens qui atteignent 100
ans dans les nouveaux nés des ces années
là dans le monde vous avez quatre
endroits qui s'appelle les blues zones
qui sont donc la montagne de sardaigne
l'île grecque d'ikaria la presqu'île de
nicoya au costa rica et lille l'île
d'okinawa au japon par exemple j'ai un
vidage en sardaigne qui fait 3000
habitants et où il ya eu en tout et pour
tout 47 centenaire qui ont vécu là il y
aurait près de 80 centenaire en
martinique les deux plus âgés sont au
saint-esprit long 110 ans
les deux chercheurs belges et estoniens
ont déjà parcouru 90 pays pour compléter
le recensement ici leur marathon a
débuté hier ils ont cinq jours pour
faire les trente quatre mairies du pays